اخر ورش العمليه السياسيه والاولى في
تاريخ السودان ورشه الاصلاح الامني
والعسكري هي العنوان الابرز في خواتم
العمليه السياسيه اكثر من 250 مشاركا
ممثلين من كافه الاجهزه النظاميه وقوى
مدنيه اما قاده الجيش الذين شاركوا في
الورشه دون اعلان مسبق فقد وضعوا النقاط
على الحروف هذه المشاركه التي اريد بها
استغلال القوات المسلحه لدعم جهات سياسيه
او لفرض دكتاتوريات او لمسانده حكومات
شموليه نريد لهذا الامر ان يتوقف نريد ان
نبني قوات مسلحه قوات ملتزمه
هنا تدور نقاشات حول امكانيه تنفيذ خروج
القوات المسلحه والقوه النظاميه الاخرى من
الحياه السياسيه بالاضافه الى تنقيه
المؤسسه العسكريه من عناصر النظام السابق
ودمج قوات الدعم السريع والحركات المسلحه
في الجيش عمليه الاصلاح الامني والعسكري
ليست مهمه سهله ليست مهمه سهله لكنها
ضروريه كجزء من الاصلاح من اصلاح الدوله
ولذلك فان الوصول للجيش الواحد هدفنا
جميعا
ونسير فيه بقناعه وفقا للمسائل الفنيه
المتفق عليها تظل الجداول الزمنيه للدمج
هي العقبه التي تتصارع حولها الاطراف دون
الوصول اليها لكن رغبه اطراف العمليه
السياسيه قد تسهل من صعوبه المهمه
اهم ما تخرج الورشه تحت الاصلاح الامني
العسكري في اربع يوم التاليه اللي هو
اليوم الليله 26 لحد يوم 29 هي المعايير
والمفاهيم المطلوبه للعمليه الاصلاح
الامني في الاجهزه الامنيه المختلفه بعد
فتره من السيال وطول انتظار التئمت هذه
الورشه لكن يبقى السؤال مطروحا هل سينجح
المؤتمرون في وضع خطه محكمه لجيش قومي
واحد يلبي تطلعات السودانيين الطامحين
للحريه والسلام والعداله سالم الهاشمي
العربيه الخرطوم